hace 100 días Colombia recibía el primer
presidente izquierdista de la historia
del país Gustavo Petro llegaba con la
promesa de cambio poco tiempo después el
nuevo mandatario hacía un primer paso
para cumplir con el principal eje de su
campaña presidencial sancionar la ley de
paz total abriendo la posibilidad de
negociar con grupos guerrilleros como el
ejército de liberación nacional o las
disidencias de las FARC una firma
cargada de significado pero que no deja
de plantear dudas y desafíos como
explicó Néstor rosanía para Franz 24 hay
que hacerlo pero no se va a lograr
porque de las disidencias de las
fallamos en la segunda o hasta en la
tercera generación lo mismo pasó hace
más de 30 años con el Cartel de Cali El
Cartel de Cali negocio con el gobierno y
apareció el cartel del Norte del Valle y
una nueva espiral de la violencia otro
triunfo del nuevo gobierno fue la
aprobación en el congreso de la Reforma
tributaria que busca generar justicia
social Aunque impone más impuestos a las
personas más ricas del país Petro tuvo
que renunciar a puntos como grabar las
pensiones ele esta protesta nosotros la
realizamos porque estamos en contra de
este gobierno de izquierda que se eligió
no estamos de acuerdo con las reformas
que están haciendo en el plano
internacional el presidente se apresuró
para cambiar de tono en las relaciones
con Venezuela
abriendo la frontera terrestre con el
país vecino un acto simbólico que sigue
teniendo grandes pendientes logísticos y
prácticos pero celebrado por el
mandatario y es un día histórico
para la región para el país para América
del Sur después de 100 días petrotrasó
con firmeza Los Caminos de su agenda la
gran pregunta que muchos se plantean es
como los encaminará a sus objetivos
finales